Hillary Swank showing off her baby bum I
know it's just so crazy listens to be a
mother of twins shared this festive pic
with her growing belly on full display
the snap of Hillary decorating her
Christmas tree was captioned quote all I
want for Christmas is you oh babies
it's like whoa in October the 48 year
old actress announced she's expecting
not one but two babies with husband
Phillip Schneider during a visit to Good
Morning America no this is um something
that I've been wanting for a long time
and my next thing is I'm gonna be a mom
thank you
and not just the one but of two oh
really yeah
we probably should have led with that
one for two years I would say day in and
day out I'm very blessed
as a couple waits for the arrivals of
their bundles of Joy Hillary also
spilled some details behind her
pregnancy Journey while stopping by Live
with Kelly and Ryan what does twins meme
that's twins means too yeah my
grandmother was a twin my husband's
grandmother was a twin oh my God so we
have twins in our in our linear in your
DNA yes the actress admitted how during
her first trimester she tried keeping
the news a secret from the crew of her
show Alaska Daily but my clothes started
not to fit so I had to the other day cut
about this much out of the back of my
jeans cut them open and then I had to
put a jacket on that wasn't in
continuity you know it's like right sure
it didn't match no and the the script he
comes and she said you know that's not
in continuity and I was like oh I think
it works and she's like it doesn't I'm
like so I'm just gonna make it work
she's like you're an executive producer
you can do it but this is weird EC was
with Hillary on the set of the drama
series where she explained what gets her
excited about the show for me
um it's a show that I find really
intriguing it's intriguing it's smart
it's funny
um it deals with real life but it also
deals you know with with real life
there's there's like drama but there's
also levity and it kind of encapsulates
everything and you know journalism
doesn't only cover really heavy stuff
there's light stuff too in a paper you
get the gamut through a to d or whatever
it is and
um and you'll see all of that the whole
rainbow
Outsiders come to Alaska to disappear or
to reinvent themselves which is it I
came for a job I'm a reporter the
character is a a strong woman who is
very driven to find the truth she's a
truth seeker and
um all of those things just enticed me
fans can watch Alaska Daily when it airs
Thursdays on ABC in the meantime we love
seeing Hillary light up with joy as she
continues on her pregnancy Journey
[Music]